if you haven't tried already to write
your own recursive fibonacci function i
really encourage you to do so or at
least to try to do so give it a serious
attempt before you watch this video but
if you have done that or or if you're
feeling lazy
i guess you can watch this video and so
we're going to try to write a recursive
fibonacci function
according to the specs that i laid out
when i first set up the challenge to
write a fibonacci function so i'll call
this fibonacci again fibonacci
fibonacci and it'll take it it has an it
has a parameter here n
so someone will have to pass an argument
to it to say which term do we want of
the fibonacci sequence but here we're
going to do it recursively what we're
going to see is is that it's actually
very intuitive to write a fibonacci
function recursively all it's all it's
almost like magic and later we'll see
though it's not necessarily the most
efficient way to write a fibonacci
function so what i'm going to do is
whenever you whenever you write any
recursive program you really need to
think about the base cases really well
in the base cases of the fibonacci
sequence there's actually two base cases
there's the zeroth term and the first
term and those are really given by
definition so let's just say
if
if we want the zeroth term so if n is
equal to zero
if n is equal to zero
well that means you want the zeroth term
and the zeroth term is actually zero and
you could say
else if
n is equal to one
n is equal to one then you
then you can return
you can return one because that is the
zero term is zero the first term in the
fibonacci sequence is one and now here's
where a little bit of the magic happens
otherwise
otherwise return
and this is really cool here
return
the fibonacci
fibonacci
of n minus 1 so whatever the previous
term in the fibonacci sequence is
plus
fibonacci
plus fibonacci of n minus 2. and i think
this should work and that's why it seems
magical because all we're saying hey
look if you want the zero term it's zero
if you want the first term it's one let
me put some spaces here if you want the
first term it is one if you want any
other term if you want any other term so
else if you want this is else if
but else if neither of these are true if
it's neither 0 nor 1 if it's some other
number it's going to be and we're going
to assume that you're inputting some
some non-negative integer over here
right over here
this would break down if you if you did
something non-negative integer over the
non-negative uh term but if assuming you
have a non-negative integer then you say
look if it's if it's not the zeroth term
of the first term then just take the
fibonacci of the of whatever one term
less than it is plus two terms less than
that and you could try it out for
example let's say you took fibonacci of
two
or then n is not zero so you won't do
this n is not one so you won't do this
so you'll say return fibonacci of 2
minus 1 so that's fibonacci of 1 plus
fibonacci of 2 minus 2 plus fibonacci of
0. well we know fibonacci of 1 evaluates
to 1 and fibonacci of 0 evaluates to 0
so it'll be 1 plus 0 or just 1. and you
can keep going try fibonacci of 3. it'll
work because we know fibonacci of 0 1 or
2 works because fibonacci of 3 will boil
down to fibonacci of 2 plus fibonacci of
1. we know that fibonacci of 2 is 1
fibonacci of 1 is 1 so it'll be 1 plus 1
is 2. so it'll just keep working and we
could try it out let's just save this
actually didn't save the file name let
me call it recursive fibonacci
recursive
fibonacci
fibonacci it's a dot py file and now let
me actually run the program and all this
does is define the function and in my
environment and then i'd actually have
to call the function so let me just run
it
and let me
ask for fibonacci of
four
they gave me the right answer
fibonacci
fibonacci of
fibonacci of 10 55 right answer
fibonacci
i could try simple things fibonacci of
zero the zero term is zero so it all
works out so that's why recursion is
kind of magical and if you wanted to
simplify this anymore you might
recognize hey the zeroth term of the
fibonacci sequence is zero the first
term of the fibonacci sequence sequence
is one so really it's if you're looking
for the zeroth or the first term it's
really the same thing as that number so
you could actually maybe simplify this a
little bit if you assume that someone's
going to input a non-negative integer
over here you could say something like
if n
if n is equal to 0
or n
is
equal or n is
equal to 1
or n is equal to 1
return
return n let's see if this works so this
simplified our code up a little bit
so let's try to save this and now let's
run it
let's run it
all right and now let's try
fibonacci
fibonacci of 10. it still worked because
really the zero term is zero and the nth
term is or the first term is one so it
works there or you could even simplify
more if n
is less than 2 that should also work
because then if it's 0 or 1 you're going
to return n and otherwise you're going
to do all of this business so let's try
that out
so let's try that out so we ran it and
let's try
fibonacci
fibonacci of fibonacci of 10.
now it seems like the computer's able to
do this really quickly and all of that
and all the rest of it but if you really
want to see all of the work that's being
doing all being done all of the calls to
fibonacci what you can do is let's put a
print in here so that every time
fibonacci gets called it prints it
prints
fibonacci
it prints the text fibonacci colon
and then
i'm going to add to that string to that
string of text
what what the argument is what the
argument is so the argument in this is
going to be n and i want to make sure
that it is viewed as a string so i'll
put i'll put it i'm casting it to a
string that's essentially just taking an
integer and making sure it's a string
and then when i add it to this string
it'll make it one big string but let's
see what this does and i'm going to try
it out with lower values first so let me
so that's the function is defined so let
me write fibonacci
i can just
let me do fibonacci of 3.
so notice when i called it called
fibonacci of three then to do fibonacci
of three had to call fibonacci of two
and fibonacci of one and then to do
fibonacci of two it had to call
fibonacci it had to call fibonacci of
zero and fibonacci of one so it had to
do all of these calls to fibonacci just
to calculate the fibonacci of three and
then eventually it gave you the answer
if you did like fibonacci of 10 it's
going to go really crazy so i'm not even
going to do that let me let me just do
fibonacci of like six and you're going
to see how many calls to fibonacci it
had to do so it had to do all of these
calls
all of these calls to fibonacci so it
was actually a very computationally
intensive thing to do but it you know
the computers are super fast so you
don't even notice it but in the future
we'll talk a little bit more how do we
think about how computationally
intensive different ways of implementing
a function can be